all right Mel first things first
congratulations are in order your jersey
retirement big congrats huge huge moment
um first off how did that feel just
being there and soaking that in for you
it was dope um I'm kind of like not the
biggest person with like putting a big
Spotlight on myself and I didn't know
how I would feel like days before
because I'm so like like just in the
moment type of guy but when I got there
it was just like it was ridiculous just
like love from the fans and had a little
video from like all my past teammates
and friends and I was just like this is
really dope see my family like I I love
that my family was more excited than I
was I'm just like I don't know I think I
came and did my job every single day and
worked hard and played hard so uh it was
really dope and a great experience the
thing that stuck out to me from that is
when you said that you never thought
that day would come yeah because if you
weren't thinking about that right what
kind of player did you think that you
were going to be at Villanova and then
at what point did you start thinking
maybe that day will come my jersey does
get retired yeah um it's crazy because
coming out of high school wasn't the
craziest like big like recruit but um I
just wanted to play like when I got to
college it's like all right you play at
the highest level in high school like I
play a was probably the ebl was probably
the highest for me against like you know
like every team I played is everybody's
in the league now so I got to college
I'm like okay I just want to play
college basketball I want to like be in
that atmosphere and I registered my
first year so now I'm like all I'm
thinking about is just I want to be out
there the next year and I came out the
next year and just try to get better
every day and
probably winning probably my after my
senior year kind of was a thought but
like my now my mind's on the NBA so like
I'm not thinking like I'm going get my
jersey retired and and but I think when
jayen when Jaylen got his retired I was
like okay like I'm I'm kind of feeling A
vibe but like you know jaylen's like you
know player of the year so I'm not
really tripping I'm might he's Jaylen
Brunson like what the hell like I'm not
tripping that much so they brought the
idea up and told me they were going to
do it and I was just like I was like
that's dope I appreciate it but it's
just great because playing on great
teams you know you get the you know
ability to have such a beautiful thing
like that yeah okay well I asked two
people coming into this things I should
ask you one of them was Josh Hart he
said please just you know say how was
Josh busting his ass so much in college
so that is the question from from
Josh they I was told verbatim tell you
that Josh was a bully in college oh
please tell me oh let's tell the story
um I was a freshman young freshman
18 and we was in practice and we have
like this side out bound play that we
run every single time so obviously on
defense like I know to play so he calls
me a hack but like yeah I think he was
upset cuz I was like packing him up you
know in practice cooking him a little
bit just on defense on defense on
defense and I got aggressive with him
and he's about to go over screen I just
like got up on him and he just Josh was
wild and he just
like picked me up like right when I went
and just threw me like just threw me
like just threw me I'm never like
everybody knows Jos Josh like yo I was
so mad like I didn't look at him I
didn't talk to him I was just like off
them right yeah and me and Josh weren't
really the closest when I first got
there and I I think maybe just because
like young guy coming in and you know
he's probably trying to seert that D
like you I'm not going to to take your
but I'm just here to you know yeah and
we weren't even that close then and I
think from after that moment I remember
I I wasn't talking like I came in
practice like I probably a talk for like
a day like I was just like off everybody
I'm just mad like I'm just mad yeah like
he tried it yeah I'm just mad and I
remember I went home and Josh like
texted me out knowwhere it's like you
good like no but I was like yeah and
then like actually ever ever since then
like we got super close and like like
best friends now so yeah that was
hilarious I was like so mad his ass he's
a bully he was like what you bully me
for what I do I just came in just trying
to play hard man I just have to say that
is such like a man apology just you good
you good I'm like would happened just
like just checking in on making sure
you're okay but ever since then y'all
are good yeah for sure I love that story
okay well then the other person I asked
was Donovan Mitchell and he said that I
should actually force you to pick your
favorite uh Villanova NBA teammate so
who in the league of course I say that
is he said who in the league that went
to fanova was your favorite
teammate
I will
only I'll have I'll have to say I'll
have to say Jaylen because I have to say
jayen
because he was our point guard and he
pretty much gave me a lot of my looks
and got me kind of like you know got me
average of 18 points so got me to the
league so I you know shout out to the
little Point guy a little little domian
over there I love that heard to he first
so Jaylen Brunson gets the nod uh for
your favorite I really enjoy honestly
reading so many things about just your
journey at Villanova and everything that
you went through there because there are
a lot of parallels between that and who
you have been in the league how your
situations have changed going from a guy
to being the guy and also just your
steady improvements so I do want to
start there because one of your
obviously biggest situation changes was
when you were traded and I've heard you
say before that you were traded at the
right time yeah when you say that what
do you mean um I think
just how my game was and probably the
confidence in myself um like I tell
everybody just the situation when I was
in Phoenix it was probably going on
for maybe how long maybe like a month
maybe three weeks but everybody was
pretty much out like the whole star
lineup and bench players so it was real
low out there and I had to like step up
in that moment to try to win games and
be out there
and be in that position for a while kind
of just really helped me grow as a
player and I was feeling real confident
got a couple big wins and so towards the
end I was feeling really good and
everybody started to come back so it was
kind of like that mindset like okay like
there's only one thing is like win the
championship and now I'm feeling good it
was kind of like that added peace
because in Phoenix at the moment
everybody saying when the playoffs come
always came down to like having a third
guy and it always like me cam
we always get kind of like bashed a
little bit because it's just like we
play off ball and it's like well these
guys need to make plays in the playoffs
you know because they're gonna take away
book take away CP so I was feeling all
good like all right like I feel
confident like you know I'm ready you
know we still got a whole half of the
Season left like I'm Gonna Keep
building so then when I got traded like
my mindset I was just like already
locked in and now like going on a team
where like I'll have like more
opportunity to score and play make I was
already locked in and so excited for the
moment you know I was sagging traded but
I know it's part of the business but I
was also really excited just like you
know okay like let me get a little bit
more shots let me be a little bit you
know a little bit more uh with the ball
in my hands and it was definitely the
perfect time cuz you were already in
some ways anticipating that growth you
were already getting ready for it
because I've also heard you say that
this moment was going to show you what
you were made of yeah did you ever doubt
that you could be the guy or did you
always feel like you kind of were
supposed to be
um I don't know I never really looked at
it like that I'm kind
of I don't know I just more I'm just
more locked in on what my role is at the
time and just getting better like
personally I just know every year like
you if I still in Phoenix whatever I
just know every year personally I just
know I'm going to get better I just know
like it it doesn't have to be right in
the beginning where like I start going
crazy it just it could take some Seasons
sometimes where like might take 10 games
20 gam 30 games I just like was just
start getting better and better but
that's just what my mindset was to get
better I never really thought about like
being a main guy this and that I just
always knew I could be a a main piece on
a championship team that's like
something to me but no I never really
thought of it like that I just this n
gonna get better and I know the label
three and D was like a thing and I was
coming out and thing is I don't care
care about labels cuz it's like you're
not you're not me you're not like see me
working you're not see what I do every
day so like label is just whatever
somebody's going to say but they don't
really know who I am and how I am as a
worker but I just knew that La wasn't
gonna be there for life like I knew that
personally like like what is that like
you know like I know I'm gonna get
better every year so I'm not gonna like
limit myself just to be a guy just catch
a shoot and play defense see I really
like that you said that because the
league has a funny way of telling guys
who they are of telling guys who they're
supposed to be when it really should be
the other way around yeah how have you
realized that you are always more than
just the box that they put you in like
nobody can tell you who you're going to
be in this league except for yourself
yeah I mean that's
just kind of how I was raised in the
mindset I have like just I think college
really helped actually even high school
just each year in high school just
getting better to where like I was a guy
come with the bench and then in that
same year I think it my sophomore
year in high school I started off coming
bench and it took a couple games where
like coach was like okay now I need you
to start and I start getting better each
day and then junior year play play and
then like mid-season my coach met with
us like okay I think Mel should be a
captain with some of you senior guys and
everybody was with it it's just like
throughout I just knew each year I'm G
keep going up and same thing with
college so I kind of just I'm like why
would I stop now you know and that's
what I'm saying with the 3 and D is like
you're telling a 20 what was 20 I was 21
when I got drafted so you're telling
like a 21 year old like he's not gonna
get better I'm just like yeah how am I
not gonna get better like now it's just
straight basketball you know it's not
like school it's not like I gotta go
school every day like now I have like
unlimited time to work on my game so
it's it's it's it's kind of goofy but I
get it sometimes with just situations
and you know I'll never be the guy like
to I always always play my role and know
how I am my role but always just try to
progress a little bit each time yeah but
I I mean I also hope you realize how
much of a testament that is to your
mentality because it does become easy to
become the projections that people put
on to you yeah like in a lot of ways it
is like a it's like a self-fulfilling
prophecy if you hear it so much you do
start to think that it's true but there
had to be something about you it said
this doesn't seem right like I know that
I am more than this so I think it's
really great that you were able to
recognize that and we're seeing you reap
the benefits of of that mentality as
well so obviously when you were uh when
you were in Phoenix you were known as
one of the best perimeter defenders in
the league and then with you being here
you are becoming one of the best two-way
players in league so with somebody who
is Elite on both ends of the floor
what's harder being the guy that has to
defend the other team's best guy night
in and night out yeah or being the guy
that's carrying the offense what's more
difficult
um I Pro I'll probably say offense for
sure for sure especially
just just I'm just like defense is like
second like second nature to me you know
what I'm saying like that's just
like like that DNA like I just was
always that Defender and I could always
just know things like that but offens is
just like making a right play and it's
sometimes
not making a right play but knowing
like I could make this play but also
trusting yourself as well like I feel
like personally like yeah I'll give the
good looks but also there's times where
like okay I work on my game and it might
be some here but also like I trust
myself I trust my work on other POS
other spots on a on a court like you
know I might have here but like also
have this shot yeah and like n n out of
10 times like I work on shot every day
and like now at times it should go in
and that one time it goes in I'm mad as
hell didn't go in so it's like like why
the hell didn't it go in so I'll
probably say offense just because they
could probably key on you a little bit
more I think
defense when you got it going you you go
on a God I think the the worst thing
that happened to you is just they just
get you off the ball like that's just
like kind of what it is you guard really
well they're like all right just throw
three screens at this dude and get his
get his ass off this guy put him on a
weeks out or something it always
frustrated me like that's always the
thing just like when you know you guard
somebody get you right off now you just
like just you just got to be able to be
okay with it and stuff like that so I
was probably say offense offense yeah
well I mean you're probably probably
realizing it definitely now but the best
defenders in the league never get the
same respect as like the best Shooters
in the league the best scorers in the
league how are you seeing that shift
just around you as being this guy now
yeah uh yeah for sure I think and it's
sad I know right because I love I love
my Defenders man I love them and it's
just CU I mean a lot of people watch the
game like it's just they see the points
and the highlights is always the scoring
highlights and stuff like that but I
mean I know there's guys out there like
herb Jones for example like I haven't
watched too many Pelican games but the
ones I do watch like it's if you just
watch him it's ridiculous what he does
like it's like really ridiculous like
what he does off ball on ball like it's
like he's like that anchor and I kind of
felt that that when I was in Phoenix
where I was just everywhere you just sit
there and just watch a tape it's like if
you're a coach and like you're a player
like you want him on your team and
that's how I felt about myself in
Phoenix like especially defensively like
oh like he's in this rotation like he
barely
fouls he's he's like showing solid
defense being smart like knowing
personnel and everything like that but
you're just not going to get that Lev
but the thing is people going to know it
is your teammates and your coaches like
they they they they know more than
anybody like they they know every day
like I know Willie Green over there is
very appreciative to have herb Jones on
his team watching film gameer exactly so
um I know I feel bad I feel bad for my
guys because you know it really is so
interesting Draymond and I actually talk
about this a lot that like if you were
going to be that guy on the team that
means if there is a defensive situation
you have to be on that Court the same
way there's an offensive situation you
say Seth has to be there you have to
feel that way about the guys that play
defense too but people just don't talk
about defense the same way they talk
about offense so how do you feel like
defense should be discussed yeah like
like I I honestly think there should be
another team like defensive team like
all team I think there should be a third
team I think there's only two because
there's a lot of really good defenders
in leak so that's like that's already
kind of showing it right there like we
got three all NBA for off offense
basically pretty much offensively you
know some will get first team maybe
because they guard but like there's guys
in there that don't play defense at all
that's first team so you defense really
don't matter and so I'm like it already
shows that there's three teams and
grateful like there's a lot of reason
why there's three because there's a lot
of good players you know what I'm saying
like guys that don't make the teams are
just like you're like like damn he got
snubbed and you say you're gonna say
that for every year in the league that
somebody's goingon to get snubbed
there's just there's not enough spots
yeah so I think it's kind of the same
defense like there's a lot of really
good Defenders where I think there
should be a third team cuz like makes it
feel even worse when a person gets SN
because it's like what it's two guard
spots y it should also just not
generally all Awards should be no
positions okay exactly yeah yeah I'm I'm
with you on that I heard you say that
defense is second nature to you yeah I
think there's few guys uh in the NBA
that maybe think that about defense cuz
that is not something that we are always
seeing yeah why do you think it's that
way the defense is not what people hang
their hat on I think just knowing I
always played I played when I was a kid
I always love getting steals I was a
uh that was funny because I used to kids
couldn't really drible with their left
hands I used to jump on I used to jump
on the right shoulder and like press up
like full court like young probably like
Elementary School like second grade or
something
and I'll jump up on her right shoulder
and when they like cross it over to the
left I'll just pickpocket and get a
layup you know I'm like it's like free
points you know so I'm just like I think
that's just me being smart I'm just like
okay make him throw it over I'm just
gonna pickpocket and just go get layup
like I just want to I want to get some
points but I think in college knowing
like when I when I was first playing
like to in order to play to be out there
you have to play defense so it's like
that's my first year playing after I R
was like all right if I want to get
minutes ain't going to be because of
scoring like I know that all the players
we had on that team that my first year
playing like ain't gonna be scoring it's
going to have to be defense so having
that mindset knowing like coaches
can't take you out the game like you you
you'll be able to stay on the on a court
longer if you playing defense and that's
how it was my fresher freshman year when
I my first year playing was like my
minutes started increasingly go up
because then coaches just like
I cannot not have him out there like I
just like I have to have him there so my
minute started to go up like even the
national championship like I came I was
the beginning that year I was the eighth
man on my rester freshman year the first
championship we won and like by the
championship like I'm finishing like I
was on the court when Marcus pagee hit
that crazy ass shot like I'm I'm on the
court for office defense like I'm out
there you know so I think just knowing
that like in order to be on the court I
got to play defense so it's just it's
always with me yeah and so much of
defense is just effort which I also feel
like it's discounted too like it's just
going out there and going hard like I
respect when you are a good Defender
because it it takes a different level of
like tenacity like I'm obviously not a
basketball player but I would think
being a great defender is much harder
than being a great score because of what
you have to do every single time you
touch the floor and you again are like a
testament to that because you're able to
hang your head on that and is why you
were able to stay out there and why
you're going to be out there for good
now I was um I was reading something
where you were talking about watching
your film against guys like Paul George
is a big reason of why you attribute
these leaps that you've made and what
has made you good just watching how you
played against people and getting better
from watching that film yeah so I want
to name a few guys and I want you to
tell me what you learned about yourself
through guarding them okay okay yeah you
can tell me you learn about yourself or
you learn about them and how it helped
you okay cool let's do it the one that I
saw first was Paul George so I'll start
with PG cool um
PG
just
like obviously how skilled he is that's
just like number one you know but just
the body movement with the ball like how
he moves and
also that's one guy like
he you got to guard him close because he
can shoot you can't go under cuz is
going to shoot the three and like so you
got to be aggressive but he's one of
those guys where I learned like you
can't be too aggressive because then
he's gonna get the foul call so you know
what I'm saying so that's why I really
learned like all right like I gotta be
solid like you can't really reach you
can't really like you know some guys get
really aggressive like uh like some guys
really like like Dylan Brooks for
example like you know but I think he's
he's kind of okay cuz that's like his
who he is so the r kind of let it go you
know it's a little you know it's a
little it's a little different sometimes
so he could play a little bit more with
his chest and be aggressive but you know
sometimes guys like me like ref see me
like bump a guy I'm like I don't even we
that much whistle exactly so PG was one
of those guys where I you have to be
super solid and
like make him make tough
shots and and I kind of took from that
offensively going a guy like that no one
like
okay any slight mess up any little
hiccup I did on him defensively he he's
going to like he knows when to get a
foul like he just knows so anytime I
kind of put a hand out there whatever
it's a foul so now it's like it just
goes in my back of my head how many
times I guard I'm like now I'm on
offense and I'm coming I'm I'm being
aggressive and once I kind of feel that
contact it's like I'm going to get foul
you know so learning from guys like that
from guarding yeah and so that's so I'll
take that from him I love I love that
answer because PG so incorrectly gets
like the the reputation PG has is not
the reputation PG should have because PG
has no flaw in his
game not at all he does not have a flaw
in his game and people have let all this
other stuff Cloud that fact I cannot
imagine what it is like out there having
a guard PG so I because do you agree
like he there's nothing wrong with how
he plays Bas not one thing he can shoot
he could dribble he can finish he could
jump he could pass you can playmake like
play defense I know you're got a little
older so maybe defense is going down a
little bit but like you know it's years
ago you know body and stuff like he
guards so he just does everything out
there okay what about Luca oh God so him
that's
a that he's more like
a same thing like Fallon wise don't
don't even dare don't even dare he's too
smart don't even don't even don't even
he's gonna he's he's going he's going
he's gonna he's gonna find that call I
think just
pace and it's it's you can say it all
you want it's like teaching people like
you know learning with Pace but some
sometimes you have it or you don't and
like just his body how he's built like
he he can play that like some guys can't
play that pace like you know what I'm
saying like he's strong and like wide so
like he could hold you off like if
you're small skinny and like you can't
can't really do that too much because a
guy can just get right back but just how
he plays and I think like the
misdirection like just kind of like
setting you up to like make a move real
quick like he'll come back slow kind of
relax and he's come at you real fast
like he's like because he's not slow
like he's slow like maybe like when he's
moving but he plays slow his gears like
he got really good Gears of like going
fast going slow to fast and back to slow
to fast again so like guarding that it's
like you got to you got to be locked in
at all times s and try to make him make
tough shots but same thing offensively
with that like you just you could kind
of learn with a like kind of pace with
him as well yeah like he's slow but by
choice exactly like he and he's and it's
good for him because he could play slow
and like he's just setting you up and
he's GNA go fast then like soon as you
take a step he's just my step back like
you know like it's crazy how much
separation gets off a step back how slow
he's going cuz he he'll go and then pop
real quick and he just separates it's
it's it's ridiculous I love it okay two
more well come to the east Jason Tatum
Tatum
um
like honestly I
think as many great things that he
does
like I think what I take away from him
is probably his finishing I think he
finishes really well like he's crafty
like he like he you see some of his
finishes he does like he's he's real
crafty like sometimes like you might be
able personally like you play basketball
your whole life and you might have like
a easy like layup like you might take a
step a little too far and go reach for
layup he's kind of smart where like
he'll make all these dribble moves and
get to the rim and then take like one
more dribble where he's already kind of
there so it missed it makes the the
timing for the guy that's getting back
to go block or the weak side like he'll
he'll move move move and then get there
so now you think he's about to take off
cuz he's like he's 69ine like you think
he's about to just go lay the ball up or
dunk it then he just like takes like
kind of like one more dribble so he
gives himself two more steps and then he
just like so that but I see you playing
it in your head exactly exactly I think
for him
just just uh even offensively just his
game like setting things up like setting
a pick and roll up like he it's like he
dribble dribbles and
then counters like he's real good at
counters too like he you think he's
about to come that way then he might
snatch back and then come back like so
I'll say it's finishing for sure but
guarding
him he's one of those guys just
personally for me like kind of with the
PG and and Luca 2 you just got to be
like those guys you gota be solid yeah
and you kind of got to study like those
are guys like you got to study like if
you just go out there just just naked
and and not know what they're about to
do all the moves they got you're going
to you're going to bite on a couple of
them and as is is over for you so and
his in and out I think his In and Out
game his in and out is is nasty so yeah
that's that's that's what I take from it
I love this I feel like I'm liking film
study okay so for the final one I'll let
you pick out of these three maybe which
one you feel like you learn the most
from yeah um Steph LeBron KD pick
one
man I'll probably I'll probably I'll
probably go with
stephh because he's very he's very
unique because it's like he's the only
guy one of only
guys where you guard he bring it up and
you got he come off all these screens
and you kind of low key feel
that you're already locked in
defensively okay now I'm about to talk
about something you're so locked in
defensively on the ball no matter what
like just at all times like you're guard
you guard any Superstar especially Stu
like you're you're locked in like he got
the ball you're like zoned in you're
locked in like I'm here you know some
screens don't go if he don't screen be
ready him to Pat Pat Michael behind the
back step back you gotta be just be
ready for him to shoot at at any
time it's just like that
just guard him off ball it's because
like you just guard even so many
Superstar guys like them off ball is
kind of like they relax like they're
kind of they do all these moves and
stuff they play they're kind of like all
right I'll let the other guy go they so
they're kind of if they're off ball like
they're they're really much a little bit
chilling a little bit but I think that
makes them just so much more lethal is
because you're used to just like all
right like I just guarded this dude for
10 12 seconds up on top of the key he
didn't get a shot off like thank God
like he didn't make so he passed the
ball go away that second
you and you like look to see like what's
happening on the other side of Court you
look back he is gone like he is gone and
everybody on his team knows it so it's
like you turn and you lose them you're
starting to chase them and everybody
setting their angles where you can't go
over or like if you go under like
they're flipping it so they're they're
just he's just non-stop so yeah he's the
most unique with like you will it's
easier to play on ball with him because
like as a Defender like as anybody else
like it's it's easy to relax off ball
than on ball you know cuz on ball you're
right here like you see it so you have
to be engaged off ball you can relax so
once you relax he's gone so yeah that's
what makes him so difficult
and and I think about step that I I take
away from
him is like personally is he's big
hockey assist guy which I appreciate
about him
like how much coverage he gets with
double team stuff he just makes the
right play you know what I'm saying
sometimes he might get crazy because
like he he plays he plays fun so like he
might try some crazy [__] sometimes but
that's just natural yeah but majority of
the time like he hit the roller or hit
the next guy and they'll make the play
because he brings two to the ball so
take that for him just like making a
simple play and I feel like
even I think in the playoffs last year I
think my coaches and stuff and everybody
was talking about like be prepared for
maybe them blitzing and stuff like that
and I'm like looking at I'm like okay
like that should be an advantage for us
like I'm not going to be crazy to hold
it and like get the hell out the way
like on no like I'll make the simple
read and then it's four and three
another end so that's what I take away
from him but guarding that man it's just
like it's that's like a 24 shot clock
like you just got to be at all times be
be prepared because once he get off the
ball it makes him even more lethal
something you said that's interesting is
how you know he
relaxes I feel like that is so
intentional by him yeah do do you agree
like he he understands that it might be
taken as though he's chilling in that
moment and and he's G you just throw it
and cut just just little his little head
W his body language cut through like ah
like all right like damn they they got
me my got me like I have the back cut
layup like they play good defense cool
and like you you like deny it like at
The Rim you like nobody threw it over
then you like turn to go look cuz the
ball's probably in the post and you kind
of like then you just like look at the
post see was about to happen and you
just look back to wherever he just came
from and from he's supposed to be in a
corner supposed to be but then you like
look and his ass is like like kind of in
a slot in the wing you're like how the
hell and then like the ball's like
getting skipped you're just you're just
praying to going because you know you
look over at the bench and the coach is
just staring at you like bro I'm like
totally like damn my fault yeah it's
like you can no nights off when you are
when you are facing it no I mean I'm
sure you obviously take every single
defensive assignment personally but is
there a defensive assignment you take
like very very
personally um
who can I say this I could take very
personally that's a good one is it's you
talk about now or in the past give me
both in the
past in the past I'll definitely
probably say Luca for sure just because
of the just the
just that just that little rivalry with
the Phoenix and Dallas and it's I mean
Ain't Gonna Die book still there it's
never goingon to Die book LCA is never
gonna die so you gon worry about that
but being there and
just just knowing that was like just
Luca's like you know the head of the
snake and and just controlling him you
know help us win the game and I think
like couple game I think my my first
start
in the in this my second year my first
year with Monty as the head coach the
first game I because I started off like
a little struggling a little bit came
off the bench I was struggling for a
little bit and it kind of came like
midseason is where coach kind of met
with us we was in Dallas and he was just
like I think like we're gonna put Mel
and star lineup now and it was kind of
like but it was kind of like a week like
now I'm not going to say a week too late
but it was kind of felt like that like
for about a week now like I should be in
a start lineup like I've been in that
Groove and like I come in and probably
finish games like it's been at that
moment but that was a game where it's
like so Dallas is always that so with
Luca so I'll probably say that and now
now I'll probably say honestly I'll
probably say jayen just now personally
just because like I just the New York
New York battle and like everybody think
jaylen's jayen is the great the greatest
dude in the world but he ain't the he
ain't the way he is on the court being
nice I'll tell you that now he's a
little fiery little like low-key [__]
talker so and I know him so I've been
practice with him and he score a couple
times and him say some [__] under his
breath and and I like not just to hide
it either like he's saying on his breath
so I can hear it like you know what I'm
saying like I hear he's like one of the
bigger trash talkers which I think would
maybe surprise people yeah he's just
he's just not really too vocal like he
might you could just you could if you're
out there you can just feel the energy
of him like you just feel him like like
all right now like you just you just
know sometimes you don't got to like you
don't got
to you don't got to hear him sometimes
you just know just how he moves and just
his pump fakes and some [__] he might
score you he might you just feel off
that you can feel that energy him just
like you know like you know he just off
like all right [__] okay Bet say less we
doing this exactly so definitely Jaylen
do you feel like you're the best
perimeter defender in the league right
like be
honest to be
like I feel like I haven't been as best
as I was at Phoenix but like that's
just it's tough I mean it's just like
more stuff going on offense and also
could help with schemes and stuff but no
honestly even now like I've been I feel
real good personally like last year I
feel like it was a little drop like a
big drop honestly but now I feel good
but I definitely S one of the best for
sure but I H for cuz I can't say the
best just basically just off what other
guys do you know what I'm saying yeah
it's it's
like see if I was still kind of maybe my
Phoenix role and not being too much with
the ball then yeah for sure but they
kind of had a little bit more
offensively kind of just takes it away a
little bit and I could just feel it
sometimes but I feel like even this year
I've been I've been way better because
when I got traded last year I just felt
like I just wasn't there like I had my
moments of course not like I can't like
I had my moments but but there'll be
times where I just feel like I'm being
too relaxed like being cut like being
cut like back screen I mean like back
cut layups like when I felt that was
happening to me in Brooklyn I was like
oh hell no Kell like you got like you
gota wake the hell up you know what I'm
saying like guys that can't defend like
I trust me I us when I was pH I get the
worst the worst Defenders on me you know
you know what I'm saying so I'll get the
Superstar guys that just dudes don't
care about and they're just like off
ball because they're ready about offense
and I'll sneak my cuts inate cuz I'm
like oh he's not going to play no D yeah
you know what I'm saying like he ain't
going I I'm not getting the best I get
the weakest of I'm get my easy buckets
so I can't person to say right now but I
mean I like I like I think that's me
just being real but I I I wouldn't I
still would't put pick nobody over
myself but I can't say I could give
myself that stamp right now you know
what I think is really interesting and
really great is you're very honest with
yourself like I I can hear it even when
you are answering your questions you're
really being thoughtful about what you
think about whether it's you or other
players and I think that a lot of NBA
players actually aren't like that they
they don't always know how to hold a
mirror up to themselves and say you know
maybe last year I wasn't or I have gone
down in this specific thing but I am
working on it yeah where does that come
from because I don't know if you know
how rare that is that people talk about
themselves in that way yeah I think it's
just
a I think it's it I think it's it it's
it's the ego issue sometimes and I we
all every human we all have egos you
know to a certain degree but you know
you kind of get platformed and make a
lot of money and you're in this in this
crazy League where you're just
spotlighted so much so you just you know
you just the ego kind of takes over and
that's just how it is sometimes and
sometimes it's not good for guys that
maybe get out the league faster than
they should or don't make it because
sometimes because the Eagles are too big
but uh I don't know I think
just I think maybe how I'm raised
honestly I give a lot of credit to my
mom my parents like my mom really just
raise honest kid and think me just
maturing as well I think I just like I
won't I won't lie about it but I don't
know I think I I I have I have my own
ego for sure like you wouldn't be able
to be what you want to be if you didn't
have that ego in you but I think I'm
just I'm a realist at the end of the day
so like I'm just I'm just I'm just is
real you know it's
like I don't know I feel like it's it's
funny CU if you see this whole thing
with
the with like the sport betting and guys
like I think Malik Monk and like both
him and herder like my boys and like
they TW like I don't care about your
parlays and stuff like that like the
thing about me is they're mad and the
thing is
like yeah there's times where like oh
for sure you play bad and you I go on my
phone and I'm like just on internet and
stuff like Instagram whatever oh
comments people are people are so funny
because they're mad ruthless like you're
the worst like d it's so funny but the
real ones are really just like be really
frustrated because like this and that
like I feel them like I'm a realist like
I feel him like yeah like I messed chick
up like like I want to hoop too don't
you like if I'm struggling like I don't
want to struggle like you know what I'm
saying so I I just I'm
like I don't know I'm like I'm I'm
honest real I'm like in like a people's
person I really I understand kind of a
lot so have you always been that way
though like has has there ever been a
time in your professional career where
your ego actually negatively affected
you
um yeah loky I think the start of
my the start of my second the start of
my second year first year with man as a
coach
and I think it was because my first year
and I was there and like I was defending
I was like I think I was top five in
steals and I played all every game I
started like 30 40 games so coming in to
the next year new coach stuff I'm just
like all right like I know like I like I
know I'm a like I know I'm the starter
like I know I'm one of the starters like
it's just shouldn't whatever
and I just kind of just had that like
that weird entitlement where
like I know I had to work it's not like
I'm not going to work for it but it was
more like my mind was already like oh
yeah I'm starting you know what I'm
saying and I didn't start like until
that till that Dallas game I told you
about and in the beginning of the season
I was barely
playing and and that was like a shock to
me I'm like I'm not even playing my ases
were
upset and end up talking to
Monty and
um he kind of sat me down was like
probably third it's like probably third
or fourth game of the season so it's was
early but you think about I'm coming
into the year thinking like with that
ego like I'm playing like I should be
playing like 25 like 30 minutes like you
know I'm thinking of this big second
year you know and he kind of sat down
with me it kind of was really real with
me and showing my stats and everything
it was just like you know you know most
guys most coaches won't play second year
guys going off the stats of like the
year so far and stuff like that and he's
being real you know I think that was the
biggest thing that one of the biggest
thing that helped me in my career
because he told me that and also like
telling me he just like I don't think
you work hard enough and the guy that
works I was kind of confused but you
know was funny because it's kind of me
like not overthinking but like kind of
having this mindset like like I'm I
strategize everything
and me with my eego thinking like oh I'm
playing right away you know there's this
thing after practice where guys that
don't play you guys play five on five
after and me thinking like oh like I'm
playing this year like I'm playing big
minutes there's no reason like why would
I play these are guys that don't really
play that much because they can stay in
shape like I'm not like I'm not burning
myself out because I'm playing 30
minutes a game you know like why would I
do this like I have the game tomorrow
I'm I'm here I have a game tomorrow like
what the hell yeah and he brought up in
a meet and like you know like you don't
play it's like get ready it's like you
don't play and get ready this and that
and I'm like staring at him and I'm like
in my head I'm just like it's kind of
it's it's lowkey funny because I'm like
smart too I'm not gonna bash at him like
back and forth like what like no in my
mind I was just like I'm like I'm like I
know I work pretty hard like him saying
that's kind of like a I felt like what
he say you don't play you don't play get
ready like this and that and my whole
mindset I'm like see in my head I
thought I was playing so like why would
I play to get ready if I know I'm G play
25 30 minutes a game so I kind of like
looked at him he told me I was like okay
I got like like it's not like I don't
want to play and get ready it's not like
I don't want play it's just like I
didn't know but that little ego part
right there where I just like thought I
was going to just play right away with
new coach coming in besides like earning
that spot kind of that was like one
thing right there and it helped me where
I'm at right now I love that so much and
I'm sure probably in some ways did
change your work ethic which you already
thought was good for sure yeah which
stayed with you I really I really like
that story and what's really striking to
me actually is um just as I was you know
reading a bunch of stuff about you in
this story you talk about how you felt
away and you talked to manty about it
yeah you are a really good communicator
when I was listening to the podcast that
you did with um Andre ardal and Evan
Turner yeah you tell this story about
you know this moment that you have with
DeAndre and how you felt so bad about it
because he's one of your best friends
again people don't normally recognize
these moments about themselves yeah and
I'm sure that for you you realize that
just having a simple communication with
DeAndre after that is a difference
between you all's relationship being
weird yeah and it being completely back
to normal yeah so just what has the NBA
taught you about communication because a
lot of guys don't know that it's just a
simple my bad I shouldn't have done that
for sure yeah I think it's just taking
accountability think we kind of lose
that sometimes
just I don't know like like we're like
we're we're pretty pampered you know
what I'm saying like we get whatever we
want kind of and like obviously like
we're in I think person the best league
in the world and making all these
millions
and a lot of people don't say no to you
you know like with just like just
because you're an NBA player and even
sometimes with coaches like coaches and
like it's like I don't know he's just
around they don't want to hurt your
feelings and stuff like that because I
think and I get it sometimes with
coaches because they're may be afraid of
losing their job so if you say something
crazy to them you might get back to them
so I don't know this shit's crazy it is
but yeah there's so much going on but um
yeah just being accountable that's what
I really think it is and you know same
thing with a DA thing just and it's
funny because I didn't think it was you
know that big of like like you said like
being that Sil be so accountable about
that like you know like you're really
like oh that's so great of you I was
just so like upset that I did that to
him you know because that's my that's my
dog and like I felt like I embarrassed
him you know and I didn't mean to I was
just mad in a moment and and I was just
I could have just said that to him after
the game or in a huddle or something
besides like making it seem like I'm
trying to call him out cuz I know
there's guys that will call people out
so I didn't want to be like look like
I'm that type of guy like that's my boy
why would ever do that right and it's
funny because one of my coaches came up
to me the next day that really doesn't
really like talk too much whatever and
he just came up to me it was really like
that was like you don't understand like
that was really like just amazing what
you did like in front of the whole group
and stuff I'm just like I was even
thinking of that man I just want to
apologize my boy I was over there
getting emotional about it I was even
thinking like oh if I say this in front
of the group like it's going to make no
like I just want to apologize to my to
my brother and stuff like that so I
don't know I think I think I think this
I'm blessed and raised right because
it's so natural I don't have I'm not
trying to like win nobody's heart over
because I'm trying to be like oh this
good guy like trying to have this
Persona think just who I am yeah no I
mean I I have been doing this a while
and I mean I'm sure as you know you'd be
surprised the amount of just like little
beefs that exist because somebody didn't
just do what you did and so it really is
a it is a great attribute and and I
think that's really really admirable
that you are that way one thing
obviously people L Nets fans talk a lot
about is just your leadership you know
the guys really like being around you
you're fun you're Lively what have you
learned about leadership in Brooklyn
um yeah I think just trying to be the
person I am and always just I feel like
if you're close off to court it's
easyier on a court so if you get on
somebody it's not like you feel like
you're taking a shot at them because
it's like no like I'm so close to you
why would I feel like why would I take a
shot at you I'm just trying to you know
I'm trying to win and obviously still
something to grow at because even at
times I get
frustrated and I'm so I'm I grew up only
child grew up only child stubborn
spoiled so it's like a lot of times like
where especially growing up like I'm mad
I don't talk like I I just I'm like I
just sit there and I'm mad and that's
like a thing where I just it's tough cuz
that's how I would grow up with but I'm
slowly getting out of it and um but
that's like one thing is L where I got
to improve on is just being so
frustrated sometimes because I care so
much and sometimes I deviate to
just you know and then being so spoiled
and stubborn growing up it's like
sometimes hard to get me out you know
like coaches or players or somebody
trying to like you know like come on
it's like I hit a point where I'm like
I'm mad you know what I'm saying right
and I'm not gonna say anything exactly
and like like a spoil brat like I grew
up with spoil brat like
so thanks Mom but uh that's
just that's one thing get better at but
yeah just turn leadership just knowing
that it's like never about it's never
about me you know even it's even if it's
like me wanting the ball and a play
happening like I'm not just wanting the
ball to score like just go score and
like oh I want to score my points like
no like if I want if I'm getting
frustrated and not having a ball is
maybe because maybe we're not scoring I
know and I have confidence in myself and
I know like I can make the right read I
can make the right play and so I'll get
frustrated on that end and sometimes if
it feels like if it's coming off like oh
like I'm selfish and I care about
scoring like no I'm just like I'm really
passionate about winning and I know I I
think I know pretty good amount about
the game so I feel like when I have the
ball I can make the right play you know
so just kind of battle that a little bit
and leaning that way and don't let it
come off as just me like want to just
jack up shots because you know the thing
is I don't think it's too much me either
I think it's sometimes just the world
you know sometimes just the social media
and stuff talking about like oh like
even like last year me Aver all the
points like oh like Kell come here
dominate score all these points this and
that so you know people might think they
see that like oh he's probably thinking
like I'm might just going to just get 30
every time and just score all the time
like yeah like I want to score but like
I'm scoring cuz I think it's the it's
the right way I think it's a way to win
you know what I'm saying like I'll I'll
make it I'll make the open read like I'm
not a selfish dude like like when I get
in them situations where I'm mad with
the ball like I'm here because I know I
have a high percentage of making a right
play also too when somebody normally
when someone is coming out of a
situation where they were like a role
player you H you still have that
mentality of getting everyone involved
yeah because you know what it was like
being that
guy yeah when people got you involved um
and so I'm sure like in these little
ways that is also baked into how you
play you're always going to want to try
to get the guys involved and I mean
people really do speak so glowingly
about you so I I hope that you do know
that and you hold that close to if you
had to put like a number to it how many
handshakes do you
have in a like in a world in the NBA in
the so but then now also in the world
because I'm
curious just walking around people have
hand no I got a lot I got a lot I still
got I'm trying to think I pretty much
got all my
teammates me who I just made me and
Harry JS just got one we was in Miami
just made one up because I always want
to make a handshake up that means
something yeah you know what I'm saying
I want to be something times random like
some might be random but it's always
like I want to have a like a moment
that's why it's easy in college yeah
because a lot of hand could be like
inside jokes you know and me HG got one
it's kind of like me like because he
love he always gets a haircut you know I
got a cut so we was in Miami we both got
a both got a haircut and the barber
pulled to my room so I already know HG
is Big He bro he stays with her cut like
every week I swear to God I'm like yo
bro how do you get a cut every seven
days it's crazy and and so I was kind of
like you know what I'm going to build
that in our handshake and I kind of
thought about it like the next day after
we got the cut and it's like me like we
do a handshake that's me like lining
them up and I like pass them like the
mirror he like looks at it and then we
like jump so it's like things that kind
of mean something I love it yeah okay I
do want to hear the number but you
saying that I want to ask which of your
handshakes has the best origin
story uh that you can tell us yeah know
I'm trying that's what I'm
trying is this what my team with the
with the Nets or just in any that you've
ever had in the
NBA um I'll probably I'll have to I'll
have
to I'll probably have to go somewhere
Phoenix let me think about somebody
Phoenix we just because so many years
with people
um see cuz C pain yeah I I could say let
me think me c pain bro we change your
handshake
like now it's like simple when we see
each other but when we do like our
pregame stuff would be
ridiculous
um there's so many I think one of my I
think one of my my funniest
ones might be with ish Wayne wght okay
what is it is like we like like d up and
then it would turn to like getting like
a handoff in football and it's like ever
since it's been here like you know how
he's built you see big that dud so it's
always like every time I see him like
look he got shoulder CP always say look
like he got shoulder pads on it's like
the funniest thing ever so look any
played in NFL like he was in training
camp everything yeah so I always say he
look like a football player so I'll say
that's one of my favorite ones because
like every time I see ish even if I
tweet something about him it's always
about him being just strong as hell just
big oy ass so that having that hand sh
where we like and we say like we always
say like said Hut like you know what I'm
saying and we just like act like we're
like getting a hand off so it's just
probably one one my funniest ones just
because it just I like that yeah I love
so then how many what was your number
teammates pretty much everybody on the
team and that and then those have
multiple like you have multiple
handshakes with guys that you have and I
I don't I don't know the memorization
skills that goes into this because so
many guys have so many handshakes and
I'm just like where is it stored yeah
cuz I got I got see and I got some
randomly from
like from like
uh other teams like like like me and RJ
got one which is actually
hilarious that's a funny that's that's a
funny story just seeing him in New York
and just having yeah I love you so you
see your opponent and you just do your
handshake before the game like I like it
like it be like layup lines and I'll see
him and we do like the uh it's like
um like the like big glow like glor when
should do like the the step like the
couple
steps so I'll see him I think we just I
think it was like in the it was just it
was a night and you know just I saw him
out and we was just having fun and that
song came on we end up just doing it and
I'm like you know what we G end that
[__] to handshake like so every time I
see you this is baked into our handshake
I love that you also of course have one
of the best celebrations yeah yeah are
you like yeah it's I love I love my
silly and it's crazy cuz now
like been I've been missing I've been
missing I'm getting it back I feel good
now yeah you didn't miss against the
Sixers yeah know what I'm saying and I
had one foot out of bounds but it should
have been another one but uh yeah
because now I could kind of do it a
little bit more funny besides like using
my hand all the way out and stuff now I
could sometimes just do it like goofier
so like I'll kind of like tuck it like
I'll kind of like tuck it and like and
just like do a little like with a stupid
ass face on my like stupid look on my
face so that's what funny because I can
kind of evolve it a little bit yeah and
then when I got that Tech in
um in in in the World Cup against Italy
I got a tech for doing it so my goofy my
goofy ass I'm like okay I might go get I
might go get tied next time so I
remember I hit another three and like I
was about to do it and I'm like you know
what [__] it so I like look down at the
ground and start doing my celebration
ground like all right like I'm not it's
not not I'm not taunting nobody I'm just
taunting the ground so I start looking
down and so my teammate like Alberton
hilarious cuz he peeps all the little
celebrations I do yeah he's so funny so
he peeps everything and you can see how
he plays how fun he plays so like he
sees all that little stuff and I
remember he brought that up like you're
just so dumb I'm like what I'm like I
saw you you know what I'm saying I just
like like you know well uh something
that I I always try to do on shows if it
makes sense is I have messages from
people and I actually have a message for
you uh
oh
okay appreciate you taking our
celebration out there to the court
showing some love to San Diego you know
we got a huge fan base out there um we
got a lot of people who support you now
um for uh you know doing that special
thing out there that we do as a
celebration as a team taking out on the
court while you make threes while you
ball out and uh you know make the game
exciting that's what it's all about so
uh appreciate the love San Diego fans
love you you we got Mass support for you
as well and uh you know wish you nothing
but the best keep Bing out this year
stay healthy and uh ball out so uh I
know I can't make a three I can hit a
homer yeah wish I can hit a homer you
know what it
is you got to do it back to it facts man
facts yeah that's and it's crazy I'm the
I'm the biggest like Phillies fan so
like it's actually funny that like I got
a celebration from like a team that's in
the NL and like we played in the
playoffs a couple years ago so but yeah
that's big Manny fan even in my little
uh I play a little MLB to show I did a
little like a little franchise League he
was like my first pick like I [__] with
Manny you know I love that yeah I'm like
so I got him he was up there I'm like oh
yeah like for the culture I'm like for
the culture that's how I draft guys I'm
like for the culture so we also love
like the the baseball NBA crossover like
I I like that cuz I'm sure there is you
know not everyone watches baseball so
I'm sure there are some nuts fans that
see your celebration know where you it
from and are now probably like tuned in
a little bit so shout out to Manny for
doing that also shout out to Dexter uh
for helping me get that video I I was
really happy when it came through um
before we wrap one of the big things
that we are doing this season is making
sure that we shine a light on people
that have helped you get to where you
are so tell me who has given you the
biggest assist off the
court can
I can I say can I say somebody just
outside my mom cuz I can say my mom
every single time about every interview
cuz I love her so shout out to Mom
obviously you're always number one so
give somebody else some love
um honestly like what I was talking
about ear I think coach Monty like coach
Monty Williams
like
just I think just him being in my life
helped me grow just as a human obviously
as a basketball court but just as a
human you know and
um that's was just I appreciate him so
much even with life and I think it's
just bigger than basketball with him and
always like it kind of weird to forget
that he's like another coach and like
especially in the East Eastern
Conference but I just always checking in
on him see how he's doing um he just
helped me grow so much and you know it
was it was a little rocky in the
beginning like I was talking about but I
think towards the end like our
relationship got so close and
he start like he started to realize like
my humor a little bit so now like he
would like he'll like he'll throw some
jokes on me and it's funny in front of
the whole group like when he was in
Phoenix like he would just say some
slide stuff about me I'm like that was
funny though you know I'm like all right
okay I see you with the jokes so I'll
say Monty just
um just him I think the biggest thing I
take with me every day it's like even in
my like little IG bios just like never
lose Faith you know what I'm saying like
and that's just
something that I just have with me when
I play and everything about life just
like don't lose that Faith like just
always kind of be happy you know even
when stuff gets tough which is tough you
know everybody like times get tough you
could you know be down be upset and
which is normal to be upset and mad like
I'm not saying I'm never mad and upset
but just like just to Never Lose My
Faith especially in a sport we play you
know you just you kind of get caught up
and like wanted to be the best at
something or be better every single day
and then you know sometimes like you
think you prepared so well and then you
struggle then it's like you know it
hurts because you like you you you
prepare so much for a game and you're so
excited then you walk off the court
shooting like freaking four for 16 now
you're like I I swear I felt like I was
so confident coming in I was just
everything was feeling good yeah so just
never lose my
faith on situations like that just
always keep keeping a love for the game
and love just in life and everything so
I'll say Monty Williams that is such a
special answer because there is a real
true power in a good coach yeah you know
and somebody who has really impacted
your life in that way what is it about
who Monty is that resonates with you so
much just how he is is a it's like a
like a person you know it's
just it's like Beyond just coaching
and I already have I already have a
father in my life and but it's just like
just how manty gives off like he just
you feel like you're one of his kids you
know like he just feel like he adopts
you and like I said it's like even like
with Steph like you know like you you
you miss you miss him on assignment and
you know he about to get a wide open and
catch a shoot and you mess up and he
makes it you just kind of just look at
the bench and he's just like staring at
you like like like a mad like you know
like so it's just like I'm so
disappointed exactly like you know
better so so stuff like that he's just
like it's just such a great dude and I
think it's
always there's times where like you're
struggling in basketball and like
because we're we're competitors and this
is our job so you're going to get really
frustrated when you're not playing well
and he kind of lets that off your
shoulders a little bit and just like
about being grateful and you know is
bigger than basketball so kind of like
even when you do struggle and you know
you still should be you know upset
because you care so much it's an okay
thing but don't let ever like take over
where it's just ruin your day every day
and so I think kind of like when I'm
struggling especially when I was in
Phoenix when I was struggling games and
he'll come talk to me and you know when
you're coach cuz you know you feel like
you're letting your team down more just
like yourself like I'm a big team guys
so like if I'm struggling I'm mad at
myself cuz I'm not helping my team out
like I know like I'm playing bad so like
we lose it's I put like a blame a lot of
blame on myself it's like I let my
coaches down I let the fans down I left
my teammates down like stuff like that
and for me to be so I'll be down on
myself like damn like I don't want to
look at guys sometimes I'm like if I I'm
like like you know like my fault and
I'll come in the next day or something
and M's like just like happy and I'm
like you know know I'm nervous coming
the next day like damn like I play bad
like you know like people going to be
mad at me or something that's how my
mind just thinks and he's just like you
know just happy is just like you know
and it kind of makes me relax like kale
calm down like you're so thinking like
people gonna be mad at you or frustrated
when you walk in everybody's just like
[__] happens like you had a bad game you
had a bad game like we move we move so
like him giving that confence me where I
walk in like you know what like I could
just breathe a little bit like it's okay
to struggle you know everybody strle and
just like I said just like is bigger
than basketball sometimes and um so yeah
I always appreciate him that's beautiful
uh two more for you before we get out of
here but you have such a strong sense of
self and even as you talk about this you
know the never lose faith and you know
the things that you were telling
yourself as you as you move through life
there was a um a quote when you were
asked about this role in Brooklyn and
adapting to it and you said how I'm
raised and where I came from with the
things I've been through I feel like I'm
ready for the moment and always have
been what are you referring to at what
part of your life you know and what
you've been through personally most
attributed to you being ready for these
kind of pressure moments yeah I
just I just think
just I don't know I think it all
started I think it just all started when
my mom moved
me we lived in Philly and she moved me
out to the suburbs and
going to a whole new school whole new
like like I grew up in the inner city so
there wasn't like it just it wasn't I
grew up around like just all like black
people you know what I'm saying and
going to suburbs and being around a lot
of white people you just don't you don't
know you know you might see movies and
stuff but like it was new for me and I
felt it I still remember the day first
day walking in like it's yesterday first
day walking in second grade elementary
walking to a new school and my mom's
walking me in and we're walking in there
I could see kids looking at me like you
know and it's the same for them they're
like like I could tell
you no more than 20 black kids in that
school you know what I'm saying so like
I could just feel like the walking
everybody's just kind of looking at me
is obviously it's part like he's a new
kid but it's also Point like you know
like another black kid like you're just
a black kid in school and I kind of like
felt that you know I felt like that and
I think just that from that moment on my
mom always just telling me at that
moment just she told told me about like
if anything happens and be the bigger
person and stuff like that if it ever
come to like racism and all that stuff
so like little things like that I think
is just and it's me my mom so she's not
there with me she's at work and I'm at
school so just like having to be that on
my own a little bit in that situation
obviously I'm no harm but like yeah just
as a kid you don't know I'm just just
trying to make friends and you know just
in case something does like that always
being prepared and know like to never
like like make it worse on myself by
like fighting or something there was one
fight I got in middle school but I was
that was just that was D other than that
like I just always know how to respond
with it yeah and I don't know I think
just a lot of versity just going through
like just red shirting and
just just each year like I say just
improving like I just I approve every
year and whatever I'm asked to do like
I'll be ready for it and it's kind of
the same thing like I've never said I
never struggled in a situation but like
I rather have that and then something
less you know i' rather have a a role
where like you know like even like when
I was young like I'd rather have that
like okay like you're in this school
you're new like like I rather have that
feeling like okay like I know I'm
nervous and scared but like I'm ready I
can handle it type stuff so I think just
that's where it starts from and
um I think just throughout my whole life
with that and like like I said just
growing every year and especially
basketball just you know I'm ready to
take the heat ready to you know what I'm
saying like you know there games I play
bad and you know even now like I just I
feel it with the Nets fans as they
should like I'm not playing where I want
to play but it's just trying to figure
out the system we're in and offensively
defensively trying to find my groove and
find what I can do and I feel as fans on
me a little bit I feel it and but like
some some could be dumb like some could
be dumb a lot of them are just they care
so much and they they care about winning
as much as I do so they they'll get on
me but like for reasons like like I'm a
reasonable guy understand and yeah like
I I'll rather have that like yes kind of
B like Kell pick your [__] up and I've
been feeling good and just continue to
get better every day and and just
continue to grow good your mom did such
a good job of preparing you for like she
did every situation I listened to a
podcast that she did um and she was
talking about how she had you at 19 and
how she always wanted to make sure you
understood you were prepared for
everything so all this end with you
being able to talk about your mom tell
me what your mom's love feels like in
your life no great she's
just she's just one of a kind you know
what I'm saying just seeing where she
worked from like having me at a young
age
and working at like Boston Market to end
up going to like Vanguard and then Merl
Lynch and then working for the Sixers
and being VP of HR and where her job's
at now like she just keeps it's like I
wonder where I get it from I wonder from
like I keep growing and getting better
and keep going like this it's the person
that that raised me like she's just been
just going going up going up and I think
that's where I got her from and she's
just she's great I don't like it's just
so I like that's what I feel like some
as I'm like she's great like just
however I am how I am this day like she
like she made me this and I get on her a
little bit because I tell her like why'
you how why did you make me so spoiled
like why did I because I did get
everything I wanted you know but then I
also look at I laugh because as I get
older I'm just like I I can understand
like having a kid only child like you
want to keep them happy at all times you
know I'm thinking like when I get older
have kids I'm like if I give me a
daughter you're like it's over you know
so I'm like God damn so I understand so
but she was like tough on me but yeah I
just just very grateful to have her in
my life and just you know as I get older
I become more like her where I just I
don't play like I M was always funny
when I was young because she'd be like
oh you're just too nice to people
because sometimes my friends might have
money and like I end up getting
something for them other than myself
mom's just like listen like I get you're
being nice yeah but like you gotta look
at yourself first and then and I'm just
like I got you but like whatever but now
as I get older I'm like like I feel more
like her cuz I'll tell her if I do some
like you know she she's human resource
so you got fire people and stuff like
that so like you know I'd be I'd do some
like tough nose [__] and i' be I feel
like big dog I'll call her like guess
what I did today she like oh she like
she make she like oh there we go yes
that you did today she like yeah there
you go now you look like Tena son like
that I'm like yeah I feel Fierce like
you goddamn oh I love that oh my gosh
that's so beautiful well shout out to
moms she did a great job you were a
pleasure thank you for your Insight your
words all the things I really appre
appreciate you coming on and we'll be
watching you out there thank you thanks
for having me thank
[Music]
you